a scathing new report blames the fbi for
mistakes and delays in investigating
sexual abuse allegations against former
usa gymnastics doctor
larry nassar the justice department
found fbi agents learned of the
allegations in 2015
but waited more than a year before
opening an investigation
during that time nassar abused dozens of
gymnasts
jeff pickets is at fbi headquarters jeff
how's the bureau responding
well good morning there were some really
serious failures here and the fbi
is acknowledging that calling the
actions and inactions of some of the
agents involved
inexcusable and a real discredit to the
organization still
a lot of larry nassar's victims are not
satisfied that everyone involved in this
scandal
has come clean it's pretty
disgusting olympic gymnast jamie dancher
says she's
outraged dancher says she was abused by
larry nassar for years
including while she was on the 2000 u.s
olympic gymnastics team
the main reason why i came forward and
when i came forward wasn't
for myself it was to protect this from
happening to other little girls in the
future
according to the 109-page report
released by the department of justice's
inspector general
usa gymnastics reported sexual assault
allegations against nassar to the fbi's
indianapolis field office in july 2015
but the agents conducted limited
follow-up and did not
formally open an investigation into the
matter meanwhile
nassar continued to work at michigan
state university and about 70 more
girls were abused during that time it
took until
october 2016 after a news report
and a separate sexual assault allegation
was made to the michigan state
university police
for the fbi's lansing office to open an
investigation
into nassar the report also concluded
that indianapolis former
fbi special agent in charge jay abbott
violated fbi policy when he communicated
with former usa gymnastics president
steve
penny about a potential job opportunity
with the u.s olympic committee
while continuing to discuss the nassar
allegations
when girls came forward and told an
adult
the adults didn't listen larry nassar i
hate you after
hundreds of victims testified nassar is
now serving what amounts to
a lifetime in prison the only person
that is in jail at this time is larry
nassar
and it's very clear that
he's not the only one responsible for
this happening
abbott retired from the fbi in 2018 and
the justice department declined to
prosecute him
abbott's lawyer says that his client
hopes the courageous victims of nassar's
horrible crime
find peace adriana wow jeff thank you